hallo leute ich wieder einmal war nun
bekommen zu einem neuen vw touareg und
der stuhl knetsch zuallererst jahres tut
mir leid das ist schon wieder viel zu
lange her seit ich das letzte tor
gemacht habe aber ich habe mir auch
keine ausrede ausgedacht und deswegen
lass uns einfach weiter machen wer sich
an die letzte folge nicht erinnern kann
warum auch immer da war wieder was mit
marvin ich glaube wir waren wieder
zusammen und wir wollten ein eis essen
gehen genau aber lasst uns nicht lang
schnacken kopp in nacken letztes mal war
das zweite siegte 2005 heute haben wir
den 13 08 2005 wo ich habe einen
monatlich geschrieben ihr wisst was es
heißt marvin ist schon wieder im ganz
gar nicht thema ab sofort gibt es kein
marvin ich hab ihn nur genommen weil mir
so langweilig war
oh mein gott man erst mal froh eine
[ __ ] danke vanessa bitte schön du warst
du hast ein dritter film sagt ich habe
ihm nur genommen bei mir langweilig gar
nicht brauchten spielzeug in echt schwer
ich doch für ballack er ist folgt in
handball so gut sind ich auch werden
dann gute nacht vanessa das war
tatsächlich ein tagebucheintrag wert für
mich ist wunderbar 28 09 2005 das ist
schon wieder ein monat über monat her
das wird glaube ich glaube das ist
ungefähr der punkt wo digitalen buch
leere in sich zusammenstürzt heimkino
mein gott ich bin richtig verknallt aber
so hammer in robin er ist so süß und kam
so gut musik spielen hier das auch
damals geretteten typ einfach ein talent
hat verkneife immer oder für monat ich
glaube dass er mich auch markwalder
immer so nett zu mir ist dann bis bald
vanessa hiermit was es heißt wenn ein
flugzeug nett ist ist er sich verknallt
ganze hier ein fenster neun tage später
immer wenn ich robben
dann klopft mein herz immer ganz schnell
und ich hab so ein kribbeln im bauch das
ist ganz komisch nächsten beim machen
letztes mal war es letztes mal als
eingespielt hat dachte ich er hat dafür
muss ich sagen dass ich mal davon
vielleicht musikalisch bin und dann bei
der schulband ali war
und da war halt auch robin und robin
konnte sehr schön klavier spielen also
das war wirklich das konnte er sehr gut
und manchmal dachte nur für mich
gespielt hat kann doch sein
gg kg g ich glaube dass damals griff
oder sich auf 30 9 dort 2005 ich
versuche die ganze zeit allerdings noch
mal ran zu kommen
wie schaffe ich das nur hallo
er ist so süß das glaubst du gar nichts
er lacht so unbeschreiblich seine art
ist einfach so perfekt
weißt du was angriff ist auch finden
überall mädchen konnten
das ist ganz komisch so was habe ich
noch nie gespürt auf jeden fall nicht so
her
ich habe ja schon oft wohngefühl aber
nicht so kann man sich gar nicht
vorstellen kannst du ihn nicht über
seine handynummer genau dein tagebuch
wird sie auf jeden fall klären die
nummer klar oder mir ein zeichen geben
dass er mich mag
naja ein love you forever wurde im blut
vanessa berg liegt mir ein zeichen
natürlich nicht komplett gestört dafür
möchte gar nicht weiter lesen aber ich
weiß dass wir noch ein bisschen was
hören wollten das sehen
2005 ein tagebuch ich hab robbins schon
seit zwei wochen nicht gesehen es tut
mir so weh und jetzt fahre ich am
sonntag nach polen für drei wochen das
wird teuer dann bis bald robin ein love
you pl
ach ja ich habe seine handynummer
[Musik]
so macht man das ja dann ist jetzt
schluss für heute und wieder mal gibt es
den krassesten cliffhanger was mache ich
in polen autos verkaufen
was passiert mit trommeln und wo zum
teufel ist eigentlich mag ich glaube
wenn ich mit diesem buch fertig bin
werde ich einfach nur verbrennen um alle
erinnerungen mit zu verbrennen und jetzt
fällt mir gerade auf das ist ja alles im
internet ist aber was sind internet ist
bleibt doch nicht für immer
jena sondern zunächst einmal wieder und
gewinnt euch bitte nicht an diesem
schönen set denn das eine
übergangslösung solange ich keine eigene
wohnung habt da könnt ihr auch sagen
danke studio 71 schreibt sie in die
kommentare und schreibt mir mal wie es
euch so geht
hattet ihr die gleichen probleme das ist
nicht wissen
hier und da sind noch videos click da
auch noch drauf wenn ihr mögt abonnieren
könnt ihr mich hier und denkt dran
bei einer million daumen nach unten
mache ich das nächste diary also strengt
euch an